this is stumpy she gets her name from
her missing foot where she probably lost
to a poacher's snare as a baby she also
has a troubled uterus yet despite these
ailments the future of the species in
Malaysian Borneo may rest on these hairy
shoulders earlier this year a crack team
of German vets flew out to Sabah
in Malaysian Borneo to perform a first
in Sumatran rhino assisted reproduction
with the world population in the region
estimated to be fewer than 40 and
probably more like 20 the only way to
ensure the survival of the species in
Sabah may now be to bring as many of
them as possible into captivity and
perform high-tech assisted reproductive
technology while stumpy is in her
reproductive prime ultrasound scans show
that her uterus is riddled with cysts
making pregnancy an impossibility for
the moment so the mission was to insert
an endoscope into her uterus and remove
the cysts the highest priority is using
endoscopy to take a sample out of cells
pathological formation which are mainly
cysts but could be also a tumor nature
we have no idea yet what were what we
expect because we saw them only by Otis
on getting this biomass here will give
us a much better picture what
and Waterloo is an accident but after
almost an hour it became clear that the
procedure was not going to plan
Stumpy's cervix was tightly constricted
because of the phase of her menstrual
cycle preventing any possibility of
inserting endoscope to remove those
stumpy seemed unfazed by the procedure
but it does raise some seriously tricky
questions when is the right time to
focus all energy on captive breeding is
scarce conservation effort and funding
really best spent on procedures that are
so expensive
with a relatively small chance of
success and even if viable offspring are
produced using some of these more
futuristic techniques is there any point
if the wild habitat is no longer there
to take them back but for the moment a
dedicated few are determined to bring
stumpy and her species back from the
brink by whatever means necessary and
they even managed to measure her up for
a prosthetic foot in the meantime
you